this movie really is  shocked to be seen on imax i cannot wait  and cannot imagine  what it's going to look like online it's  the perfect film it's cinematic  it crosses worlds i mean the fights are  epic  the characters are iconic i just sort of  feel like it's the place  the bigger the better when it comes to  mortal kombat and you can get no bigger  than i  we all strive to make this  as mortal combat as possible the new  thing about  this particular version is just the  scale and the  elevation of it it's dense and it's  powerful and it's fun  and i think imax is actually a really  perfect way to see it  everyone involved really dedicated  themselves to making us feel  as visually wonderful as possible it  will just be a whole different  experience if you get to see it in the  cinema is there any other way to see it  i can't wait  you